did you help Lincoln clay murder Salman  Khan oh and all prominent members of his  crime family you're goddamn right I did  my head whoo baby whoo baby it's a long  way down  a long way down Marshall largest number  of casualties in the ongoing conflict if  you gets the Liffey in ER do this quiet  away from here and shake the club before  your daddy's good righteous will rejoice  when he sees the Vengeance gonna come  nothing you do Oh bring any of them back  go to the river where the water it took  me months to figure out that Lincoln had  survived the massacre was waging a war  against Salman Khan Oh  is this crazy on the cross thank you  again Ben you're not a lot  is never going to be over keep going you  got no more feel me yeah so right now  it's just you shot him once  Oh  no way down